did you know that over the last 30 years
the cost of college has doubled and in
many cases
tripled so the question is this here's
the big debate is the value that you
receive in terms of an education
has that doubled or even tripled so that
is the debate that we're gonna have
today let's talk money all we talk is
money
all we talk is money
welcome to sales talks money on
valuetainment economics i'm your host
adam sosnick and i'm here
to help you build your wealth and save
that money the question of the day
is is college worth it today we're going
to be covering
three overall topics number one a
breakdown of the numbers
number two the tail of the tape college
versus no college and number three who
should do what
so with that being said let's get right
into the numbers here's a couple quick
points for you obviously since the
internet is everywhere
social media has completely blown up
over the last 10 years
the cost of college has doubled if not
tripled over the last 20 30 years
and then last but not least student loan
debt has completely skyrocketed people
are basically saying
i don't know about this college thing
man i'm not so sure so people are
questioning
the status quo well in fact for the
seventh year
in a row enrollment in college has gone
down down down down down
seven years in a row now people saying
i'm not sure if i need to go to college
anymore
that takes us to where we are today
during covid let's break down some of
the numbers
regarding covet now during covet 64
of classes are doing a hybrid approach
that's in person and online
32 percent are completely fully online
and only four percent are in person but
here's the catch
tuition has stayed exactly the same now
what are your thoughts on that you're
going to college you're paying the exact
same price but you're not getting
the in-person education that you
typically would do you think colleges
should lower their price is it fair that
it's still the same that's what's going
on
today during covet now let's just talk
about the
overall cost of college now we're
talking overall costs we're talking
tuition we're talking room and board
we're talking books this is
all in numbers for 2020. now the cost of
college for a public
two-year college a community college or
a juco as it's called in many cases
is twelve thousand dollars a year that's
for a two year
a public four year it costs twenty two
thousand dollars that's for in-state
tuition
and if you're going to be paying
out-of-state tuition that's going to
cost you 38 000
a year now here's the big one a private
four-year university will cost you
50 000 what are your thoughts
on the cost of college all these numbers
i just told you were per year
so if you're talking in-state that's 22
times 4 you're at 88
000 for an education if you're talking
38 out of state times four
that's over a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars and for fifty thousand
dollars per year
that's two hundred thousand dollars for
four
private education that is a lot of
dope moving on what state costs the most
to go to college
well that's vermont are you listening to
me bernie sanders your state
costs the most what state costs the
least that's north dakota go bison
as i said before the cost of college has
gone up up up
education has stayed pretty much the
same what are your thoughts on that
i'd love to hear a comment below now
let's talk about the big
elephant in the room which is what
student loan debt do you know
how much student loan debt in this
country is now well it's
1.6 trillion dollars that's a lot of
dough
and that has spread over 44 million
americans so if you don't have student
loan debt that more than likely means
your friend or your best friend or your
neighbor
definitely has student loan debt now
70 percent of college students borrow
when they go to college 70 percent
and over 90 percent take out federal
loans that's a big number right there
last but not least the
average student loan amount in this
country per person
is thirty five thousand dollars now just
breaking that down only three percent
three percent have over a hundred
thousand dollars in student loan debt
that's no joke
and only one percent have over two
hundred
thousand dollars so the average thirty
five thousand dollars that we're talking
about
now one more thing of major importance
is what major
you decide to get a degree in and we're
going to break down what majors pay the
most
and what majors pay the least that's
coming your way shortly
also another theme throughout this
episode are going to be
trade schools if you're not familiar
with trade schools they're also known as
technical schools or vocational schools
it basically allows you to get a job
where you get training but you don't
need a degree speaking of degrees let's
take it to the tape it's time for the
tail of the tape
going to college versus not going to
college
now since on this show all we talk is
money let's start with the big one first
which is salary now it's no secret that
if you get a degree
your salary tends to be higher now on
average
the starting salary for a college
graduate is 50
000 and over the course of a lifetime
you're talking on average seventy eight
thousand dollars
for a college graduate now if you only
have a high
school degree your average starting
salary is thirty thousand dollars
and over the course of your lifetime
you're going to average forty five
thousand dollars that's a big difference
well how big now let's talk about
lifetime earnings if you get a college
degree you're gonna make
two million dollars or more over your
lifetime
now compare that to if you only have a
high school degree you're on average
going to make only one
million dollars over your lifetime so
that's more than
double if you have a college degree so
for people that say
getting a college is overrated take a
look at the big picture y'all
now i'm not saying that's gonna apply to
everyone but that's certainly what the
numbers show
moving right along now the average
college graduate with student loan debt
owes on average
35 000 what's the interest rate is what
i always ask people
the average interest rate is 5.8 percent
do you know how long it takes
for a college graduate to pay off 35 000
do you know how long it takes to pay off
student debt well on average it takes
between 18
and 21 years let me break down some math
for you if you're listening did you know
that based on 35
000 paying 5.8 interest
over the course of 10 years it'll cost
you 10
000 in interest so over 20 years it
might cost you as much as
twenty thousand dollars so your student
loan debt that you owe
that's thirty five thousand dollars when
in fact it might up end up costing you
forty five or fifty five thousand
dollars over the long run
student debt is no joke as you know i'm
sure now when it comes to student loan
debt if you don't go to college how much
do you owe
i can't hear you well if you said zero
you'd be absolutely correct you don't
owe
student loan debt so would you rather
make more money over your lifetime
on average would you rather have less
debt that's a big
debate and obviously there's an even
bigger gap in life
time earnings so it's up to you now
let's talk about the
buffer of college it's almost like a
four-year buffer before you enter
the real world it's almost like you're
jumping in the kiddie pool before it's
time to sink or swim
in the real world now if you go to
college it's a transition
to independence you have four years to
kind of get your [ __ ] together if you
know what i'm saying
it's a time where you can learn to be
self-sufficient you learn emotional
intelligence you learn to have roommates
you learn to cook you learn to clean
it's kind of a time where you're like
you know what
this life thing ain't so tough i'm
figuring it out but it takes some time
to do that
now if you don't go to college and you
gotta jump right into the real world
where a lot of times they say it's sync
or swim you maybe gotta get a job
immediately you start making some money
maybe just maybe you're living at home
but you got bills to pay
and that's how it works in the real
world now let's talk job
opportunities now if you go to college
you'll certainly have more options
and better opportunities throughout your
career now if you don't go to college
it's all good there's a lot of jobs that
no longer
require a degree well in fact a lot of
major tech companies we're talking
google apple ibm netflix microsoft have
all basically come out and said well
degrees no longer required want to know
why because skills
pay the bills you don't necessarily need
a degree
for a lot of jobs out there now on top
of that let's talk about
trade schools trade schools can be a
major asset for a fraction
of the cost of what it costs to go to a
four-year school now when you're talking
trade schools on average you're talking
eight months to two years to become a
specialist
in a very specific trade now i'm gonna
give you a list right now of the highest
paying
trades here's the list licensed nurse
an hvac technician plumber electrician
home inspector construction manager
dental hygienist
computer technician web developer
landscape designer a barber or
beautician
a paralegal a real estate agent and
here's the big one
sales if you can sell you'll have a job
anywhere
now let's talk guarantees now if you go
to college there is no guarantee
no guarantee that you will have success
there is no guarantee
that you will have a great job however
the odds will certainly
be in your favor now let's talk
guarantees of not going to college well
you're number one
you're guaranteed not to lose money aka
pay thousands of thousands of dollars at
school and you're guaranteed not to
accumulate a ton of debt
so that's a pretty good guarantee so
side note if you go to trade school
you're guaranteed to have a very
specific hard skill and on average the
debt for a trade school is a fraction of
what it is
for normal college you're talking about
ten thousand dollars
so not a big investment to learn a trade
now let's talk
opportunity cost or speed to market now
if you go to college
that's four years four years of paying
tuition
that's four years before you start
earning a real salary and that's four
years
before you start your career now if you
don't go to college
let's talk about opportunity cost here
now you can start making money
immediately maybe it takes you a year
two years if you do a trade school but
you're making money
way quicker than a four-year wait of
college and then you're also getting
real-world experience
immediately so obviously if you get a
job and you're not feeling the job
you can pivot to the next job and you
can pivot to the next job you might have
two three four jobs
to figure out what you want to do before
the average college student
even enters the working world so there
is some advantage
to not going to college and going right
to market now let's talk about the
social
and networking component of going to
college versus not going to college now
this is a big difference here now
obviously if you go to college it's a
very high
social experience a lot of friends a lot
of parties a lot of clubs a lot of
organizations
a lot of things to be a part of there's
an alumni network there's connections
galore and there's part of a college
culture this is a big
big thing i went to florida state
university i did not learn a lot quite
frankly but i'm still best friends with
a lot of people i met throughout college
so connections galore that's something
that you might not get
if you don't go to college now here's
the thing with social and networking
if you don't go to college well number
one obviously it's a less
social experience you're not surrounded
by thousands and thousands of students
that are your age
so you're not making those social
connections what else
there's no alumni opportunity there's no
alumni so obviously there's no
job connections now here's a little fun
fact for you did you know
that 70 of all jobs are done
through networking 70 done through
networking so what am i telling you it's
on you
to network it's on you to network no
matter what but obviously if you're
going to college there's a lot more
opportunity to network
versus not going to college so that's
definitely a plus in the going to
college
section all right so now it's time to
talk about health everything we've
discussed so far is about wealth but as
they say is health
is wealth as well now here are some of
the facts when it comes
to your health now if you go to college
you tend to live a healthier
lifestyle let's unpack that a little bit
here you're more likely to exercise
you're more likely to have health
insurance and you're more likely to have
benefits
through your jobs retirement plans 401ks
you're more likely to live longer and
your kids
tend to have healthier habits now if you
don't go to college
well there's definitely some health
risks there you tend to lead an
unhealthier lifestyle what does that
mean well that means you're more likely
to smoke
and less likely to exercise regardless
you should know that health
is wealth moving right along let's talk
about unemployment
now obviously before kova this was a big
thing now with kovid
unemployment has skyrocketed but
pre-covered the average unemployment
rate for a college graduate was 2.2
percent
versus 6.5 for a
high school graduate so that's a big
plus for the college graduate obviously
unemployment
is a big deal the x factor when it comes
to college
is if you finish what you've started a
couple quick facts for you did you know
that only 58 of college students
actually earn a degree which means over
40 percent
drop out did you hear me right over 40
percent
drop out so if you're gonna go to
college and pay all this tuition
and rack up debt and you do not finish
what you've started
it's probably best to avoid going to
college now
what's the x factor if you don't go to
college well
you have opportunities galore you don't
just need to go
right from high school into the real
world what are your options well
we discuss trade school right you can do
an apprenticeship
you can go into the military potentially
there's free online
classes called moocs m-o-o-c-s
moocs and the big one is
entrepreneurship if you just said hey
man i want to start a business i want to
do the damn thing well you've come to
the right place here on valuetainment
there's literally hundreds and hundreds
of videos to teach you
how to become an entrepreneur now let's
talk about getting a degree which is
obviously the big
payoff here if you graduate from college
hopefully you do it in four years or
close to it
you get what is known as a diploma that
pretty much validates
everything you've done over the last
four years now when you're talking
college and you're talking degrees and
you're talking diplomas
let's talk about roi on your investment
because that's why you're going to
school
is to get the big payoff now here are
the majors that pay
the most you got engineering computer
science
math and sciences business social
sciences
humanities agriculture and
communications
now there are some majors that don't pay
as well now here are the majors that pay
the least you got drama and theater fine
arts
music studio arts visual and performing
neuroscience art and music education
and early childhood education now you
listen to me and you listen to me good
do not let not having a diploma stop you
from achieving
your dreams diplomas don't pay the bills
skills pay the bills so that was the
tail of the tape now that we factored in
college versus not going to college
what should you do so here we have a
breakdown of who should definitely go to
college
and who should consider skipping classes
so you should go to college
if you know exactly what you want to do
or generally have an idea
of what you'd like to do number two if
your professional career
requires having a diploma i.e becoming a
lawyer
becoming a doctor becoming a cpa you
need to go to college
obviously if you're receiving grants or
scholarships aka
free money you take that money you go to
college
moving on if you plan to graduate in
four years meaning
you're going to college you're getting
this job done you're not wasting time
go to college get that job done if you
have a plan
to pay back the loans like an actual
plan you're not just going to
wander into student loan debt you said
all right i know i'm going to take out
this thirty thousand dollars in student
loans but i got a plan to pay this back
i have a career in mind
moving on if you actually just want the
college experience you want to go to
school for four years
you want to go to the football games you
want to do the socializing you want to
get a fraternity you want to go to
sorority i get it
you want to have the college experience
that's a big deal but that shouldn't be
the only reason
you go to college last but not least if
you're just not ready for the real world
you're like look
i'm not ready to start working in the
real world and getting a job
i'm not ready for this and ultimately
you just want to get a diploma
now moving right along who should just
proverbially skip class and not go to
college
well let's break that down right here if
you're just unsure of what you want to
do and have no clue
maybe you don't just rush off to college
especially
if you're going to take on massive
student debt that's number two
avoid massive student loan debt if the
career path you want to choose
doesn't need a degree then why are you
going to college here's a little fun
fact for you
40 of college graduates are
underemployed meaning
they're working in jobs that don't even
require a degree
what's up with that moving right along
if you don't
thrive in the traditional academic
environment
then why are you wasting four years of
your life going to college
you might not need that if people are
telling you well college is the thing to
do you're supposed to go to college but
that's not right for you
don't just go with the herd mentality do
what's right
for you moving right along if you're
ready to make some money immediately if
you're a hustler if you're an
entrepreneur
and you said hey listen this hit in the
books thing ain't for me
i just want to get working i want to
hustle i want to be an entrepreneur
i want to go go go go then maybe you
don't have to go to college maybe it's
time
to hit the real world obviously if
college is just straight up
not for you just like look i'm not into
this college thing
don't feel bad you don't have to go to
college not all successful people
go to college last but not least if
you're going to start
and like the 40 of people who drop out
and not get a degree
just don't even bother just save that
money and save those fees and go right
into the working world
so that's who should go to college and
who can avoid
going to college so now the question is
what's right for you
only you can answer that question now
it's time for my final takeaways now
here's the deal what we know for sure
is that college is just not for everyone
we get that
but you know what is for everyone you
know what's for everyone
learning being smart and being educated
learning does not stop
after college in fact i've learned a lot
more since college
than during college that's for sure
never stop learning now how can you stay
learning
well these days online the internet
podcasts
books all of that stuff and most
importantly if you just consume
the content on valuetainment there's
content galore
that is guaranteed to make you smarter
and wealthier that's for sure
moving right along what else can you do
if you're not sure
of exactly what you want to do you know
what you can do you can reverse
engineer success you can eliminate the
things
you know that you don't want to do but
at the end of the day you know what you
should focus on
becoming a specialist one of the things
they say is that the riches
are in the niches meaning a jack of all
trades who does a bunch of different
things
very rarely find success but if you
specialize in one thing
one thing you're pretty much guaranteed
to find
success the next thing you're going to
want to do is have a plan before you go
to school and after you graduate school
now before school what is your plan
going to be
well you got to understand how much
loans you're taking on what school
you're going to be going to how much
that's going to cost you
what your major is going to be and the
roi on that
major so after you graduate school
you're going to want to have a plan as
to where you're going to live
where you're going to work and how
you're going to make that
money so last but not least make sure
you run the numbers
do the math and save that
money now if you have not seen my
episode on whether you should rent
or buy check that out right here and if
you have not seen my episode on how to
win the money game
check that out right here and if you
have not subscribed to valuetainment
economics already
please do so right down there and as
always
save that money all we talk is money